I am a reaver and I was taught how to
pray salah.
>> That means every single time I pray.
>> The person who told me gets the reward
>> five times a day from fud to is
>> if you want to support someone like me
in learning salah.
>> Then sponsor 10 people for just £100
this Ramadan.
>> Remember the prophet peace be upon him
said charity does not decrease wealth.
Click the button and donate now.
Asalam alaikum brothers and sisters and
dear friends. So these videos have been
sent to me and I was thinking to myself,
is he serious or not? I show speed
except in Islam. I went on YouTube and I
found multiple videos. Um and I was a
bit taken back and I was like subhan
Allah this actually quite profound. He's
actually a Muslim. It's a firm that he's
been a Muslim for a long time now. Now
brothers and sisters I need you guys
help for me to get the guided prayer mat
to Aish speed. We are a charity Salah
Pro. We have the Salar Pro app you can
download for free. It's ads free. It's
got kibla finder. It's got all of the
features. You can book a salah
instructor order a guided prayer mat. So
we want to send a guided prayer mat that
will help him to learn how to pray
salah. We want to get it to him one way
or another. We need your help says
please get this video to him on
Instagram, Tik Tok, you name it,
whatever. Please, please, we're going to
react to the video now in see has he
really taken Islam shahada? It seems
like he has. Let's watch for oursel
inshallah. Here is the first video
inshallah. Okay. So the first video is
promises of is of him written the Quran.
So let's just look at the transition
that happens before we get inshallah
into the video of him actually taking a
shahada and saying he's a Muslim. The
second one is uh with him and u chunks.
So look what he had to say.
>> Wait, what do you want to do?
>> Make you convert into Islam.
>> Do that right now.
>> You want to do it?
>> Yeah.
>> How are you? I've got your consent.
>> Be a Muslim.
>> Yeah.
>> Are you sure?
>> Are you sure you want to accept Islam in
your heart?
>> Yeah. We're going to revert speed right
now, guys, on camera. This is a big
moment. It's going to break the whole
internet. I hope you know that.
>> Wait, what? Wait, what? Like, am I going
to die? Like, what's my dad? I think
it's time for me to pick one, you know?
You know, should I just go with my dad?
You know, should I just follow my dad's
steps and be Christian or should I like
go what I want to do? I
>> think it's a mix of both.
>> Yeah, we'll be honest. It is. I do, bro.
I mean, hold chat. What What religion is
Ronaldo?
I'm not going to lie. Whatever Ronaldo
is, as I'm not going to lie, bro, that's
what I'm going have to do, bro. Oh, so
Ronaldo is Islam. Subh that's
interesting because Allah says in the
Quran, are you going to follow your
forefathers knowing that they were in
the wrong? So we would say speed. No,
don't follow your father. I came to
Islam. I came to Islam 13 years ago. My
dad hates Islam. He's an atheist and I
can't lie to myself and to please my
father and follow his religion knowing
very well that he's on the wrong path.
So it's important for us to accept the
truth and pray that our parents can come
to Islam as well. So we hope you will be
an ambassador that your dad comes to
Islam. But let's carry on.
>> I think it's a mix of both.
>> Yeah, we'll be honest. It is. I do, bro.
I mean, hold chat. What what religion is
Ronaldo?
I'm not going to lie. Whatever Ronaldo
is, that's I'm not going to lie, bro.
That's what I'm going have to do, bro.
>> Oh, so Ronaldo is Islam.
>> Okay, I think that's a joke. But
obviously, you know, you worship Allah.
So even if Ronaldo ends up being
whatever religion, u the truth is the
truth. And even if it's someone that we
really really love, we shouldn't, you
know, that's why the prophet sallallaihi
wasallam, his uncle, even though he knew
Islam was the truth, he did it because
he didn't want to disappoint his tribe.
And we believe that he'll be in the
hellfire and because of his servant, how
he defended the prophet, he'll be in the
he'll be getting the least punishment.
Subhan Allah. I hope you guys enjoyed
the video guys. But before that, please
download the Salah Pro app. Brothers and
sisters, we are a charity. All of our
services on the app is for free. Free
kibla finder, no ads, free salah
reminders, encourages to pray, tells you
salah times. You can book a salah
instructor, a Quran instructor. You can
order a guided prayer map for absolutely
free if you want to learn how to pray
salah. Videos on how to pray salah,
salah hubs, and many, many more. Bro
sisters, we are not an app that shares
your information with third parties. All
of our services on the app is for free.
Download it now inshallah and enjoy
guys. Let's go back to the video. So
that's one. Okay, so let's go to the
next one. So here we get some interest
cuz obviously you can see here now use
the words on the bit funny.
Allah,
he's scared of that chat. When I say
Allah, he leave.
Allah.
Yeah.
Yeah. This guy is hilarious. I'm not
going to lie. He's ab hilarious. Okay.
So, here is um the first thing of him
taking the shahada. So, I don't know you
know how long he's been a Muslim. I
don't know if which one I don't know if
he knows what he's saying, but let's
watch it for yourself.
>> Very good, boy. Say always.
Alhamdulillah.
>> Always. Alhamdulillah, my friend.
>> Are you Are you Muslim or Christian?
>> I'm Muslim, bro.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So, if anyone testifies So,
somebody who testifies on their tongue
they're a Muslim. don't believe in their
heart, they are known as a monafic.
There are someone that is pretending to
be a Muslim. Anyone that believes in
their heart and doesn't say on their
tongue, they are known as a disbeliever.
They know it's the truth. And anyone
that says on their tongue and believes
in the heart, they are a Muslim. So,
let's go to the next video.
>> Aisha speed confirms that he's a Muslim.
Alhamdulillah. Please make dua for him.
Muslim I'm tired of these
call
I'm not Muslim. I am Muslim. I am
Muslim.
I'm Muslim.
Oh god I'm don't give a name. I'm
Muslim. I'm Muslim. Allah was born.
Allah was born.
>> Okay. You can see here he's under
anesthesia. So we can't really take that
as thing. But here's a video he has with
two Palestinians. You speed free
Palestine?
>> Yes. Free Palestine.
>> I am from Palestine. You're Muslim. You
are Muslim. Speed.
>> Yes, bro.
>> Okay. So, here is confirming that he's a
Muslim. He's saying, "Yes, I am a
Muslim." Yeah. Okay. Here is another
video. Let's watch for ourselves.
>> So, recently, I show Speed has
officially confirmed that he has
accepted Islam.
>> That's a brother right here.
>> Mhm.
>> That's good. You reverted?
>> Yep. How long ago?
>> Really? No, I didn't. No, I haven't
reverted.
>> I'm saying like when did you become
Muslim or were you born Muslim?
>> No, no, last year.
>> Oh, nice.
>> Mhm.
>> That's nice. Welcome. How you like it so
far?
>> Great, man.
>> Yo, you got teachers and what not
helping you out?
>> Nope, not yet.
>> You know, we got some
>> after tour. After tour though.
>> After tour.
>> A lot of people were wondering before if
it was true or just a rumor, but now we
can clearly see that he himself has said
it. This moment really shows that he's
chosen Islam wholeheartedly. After
watching the clip, it's clear that Speed
isn't just saying it for hype. He has
genuinely embraced Islam. And as
Muslims, this reminds us of the
importance of staying true to our dean
and living by Islamic values every
single day. The Prophet Muhammad
sallallah.aii wasallam said, "Convey
from me even if it is one verse." Bkari.
This teaches us that no matter who we
are, we should spread the message of
Islam in the best way we can. Even with
small actions, let's make dua for speed
that Allah keeps him steadfast and also
helps us all remain firm on the right
path. So you can see clearly I think
that's his dad there. I think they say
that's his dad there. His dad was
obviously a bit taken aback but you can
see he said that in front of his dad but
is there anything that he's he's done
his shahada. The only thing that we have
is this one this clip here.
>> Do you want to do you want to be a
Muslim?
>> So how do I like so like if I'm home how
do I do that? Like how do I like get the
>> Repeat repeat?
>> Okay.
es what?
ill
>> Muhammad
>> Allah
>> congratulation you're now Muslim
>> it's early in the morning
are you are
Yeah. What?
>> Brother, I seen I've seen everything
that you got going on and the way you
know put up for Palestine. A lot of good
things going on. I respect it, brother.
>> Thank you, bro. So, respect,
>> bro. Thanks, bro.
>> All right. B.
>> So, you can see that. Okay. So, brothers
and sisters, okay, for me, somebody
claiming he's a Muslim under anesthesia
and many people asking him is a Muslim
Muslim. So, it's very simple. We take it
from apparent and he is a Muslim and we
really want to reach out to him as a
Salah Pro project says we're a charity,
okay? We don't make anything out of
this. So guys, I really want to reach
out to him. Please, please help me. Tag
him somehow to get the guided prayer mat
that will teach him how to pray Salah.
And it's for free. It's not free cuz
it's a shallow speed. It's free for
anybody. If you don't know how to pray
salah, you can go to a Salah Pro app. S
A L A H space P R O Pro app and you can
order a guided prayer map from there. If
you have a da table, you can order a
book. If you you want to book a salah
instructor, there's salah times. There's
free kilfinder. There is no ads. There
is no subscription. We are a charity,
guys. So, subhan Allah. And we've got
some new features coming the subhan
Allah. So as my as an advice to Aisha
speed as a revert myself to another
revert Allah says in the Quran do not
say that you're going to believe and not
be tested. I shall speed you are going
to be tested and in that test you have
to show if you are really about that I
shall speed. Yes, you need to show I
show speeds in those tests inshallah. So
and we ask Allahh to make it firm for
you and may Allah bless and preserve you
inshallah and keep you firm. Know that
you have come to the one true religion
and we ask Allah subhanaa tala to keep
you firm. order the guided prayer mat
and your journey has just started and we
ask we can see that the goodness of your
heart Allahh has guided you. So guys,
you please please get this video to him
in I really want to get a guided prayer
out to him one way or another. It is for
absolutely free. He will learn how to do
wudoo. He will learn how to pray salah.
And just imagine the guys that when a
speed learns salah, learns, learns how
to pray salah, learns how to do wudoo
and you get the rewards for generations
to come of him and his offspring
learning how to pray salah and find of
course a four hijabi sisters inshallah
to get married to in too excited. That's
it brother and sisters. Inshallah. May
Allah bless and preserve you guys and
make the war for your brother show speed
inshallah and in he will show uh show
some speed in Islam is inah till next
time.